you've apologized for stop-and-frisk
repeatedly what exactly are you
apologizing for we let it get out of
control and when I realized that I cut
it back by 95% and I've apologized and
asked for forgiveness I've met with
black leaders to try to get an
understanding of how I can better
position myself and what I should have
done and what I should do next time but
let me tell you I have been working very
hard we've improved the school system
for black and brown students in New York
City we've increased the jobs that are
available to them we've increased the
housing that's available today we have
programs like this issue mr. mayor to
put people's fears and skepticism to
rest I think they just used to follow
you know well that's because it's in
their interest to promote that but if
you talk to the people in New York City
I have over a hundred black elected
officials that have endorsed me a lot of
them are in the audience tonight and
I've earned the respect of people in New
York City I was the mayor of the largest
most populous city in the United States
for 12 years and people will tell you
it's a lot better city today it is safer
for everybody the school system is
better the budgets under control we've
done the things that people need in New
York City for all ethnicities
you